foreign
that's you Dr Hein uh what's up also
doctor same person
um has come down with a respiratory
ailment that we strongly suspect is at
least what is being called the current
variant of covid well done yes thank you
um
and
let's just update people on where we are
with covet I would you tell me if this
doesn't match your your sense of things
but our sense is covet is very
definitely not a highly deadly disease
and people were spooked into all sorts
of dumb Behavior with the false
impression and in fact the cultivation
of the impression that it was deadly
including by treating people in ways
that made them more likely to die and
then counting those deaths is covet
deaths rather than aatrogenic deaths
right
that said
covet is not enough from our perspective
we've had it we've had it a couple of
times I don't know how many times
because the tests are unreliable but
we've each had it a couple times at
least and the
um negative effect the effects are
substantial during the disease and
everything that I know from my work on
telomeres tells me that the damage is
not just occurring and then over when
you get better not only are there
holdover effects from covid but there is
also the long-term degradation of your
capacity to repair whatever tissues are
under attack
yeah so when you say not as deadly a
disease by a lot as we were led to
believe
uh
you are
um also implying but not it's not in
that statement something that you said
very clearly some what early in our live
streams which is that just because a
thing doesn't kill you doesn't mean that
it doesn't bring death closer right and
in fact almost every disease even
presumably something like a cold does
this so trivially that it's it's
negligible in its impact but the point
and you know if you have a bunch of
damaging diseases and then you die
because you don't look both ways and you
get hit by a bus obviously it didn't
hasten your death but on average you die
from the failure of whatever organ is
essential and collapses first or you die
of a cancer that's basically the two
general Ways to Die naturally yeah and
um in the case that you die from organ
failure each organ has a capacity to
repair damage and do maintenance and
that capacity is finite and anything
that does damage reduces it borrows from
that account and so uh you know if you
do a lot of damage to let's say you do a
lot of damage to your kidneys early in
life and then you wise up and you stop
doing damage you know you can compensate
a bit you can't buy back anything you
lost but what you can do is you can
reduce the rate of damage to below
average and you can sort of catch up but
all of that stuff you can do that better
in tissues that actually have some
repair capacity and not in for instance
the heart as we have talked about a lot
right even though your behavior should
be the same right you can't recover that
capacity by uh well I guess you could
reduce the rate of damage of your heart
by being super Vigilant of new damage to
your heart
um but yeah the the heart doesn't repair
in a classical sense it scars over which
is still uh much better than having an
open open wound in your heart which is a
lethal vulnerability but anyway this is
a bit of a digression we treat covid
seriously even though we don't fear that
we're not going to get through a case of
covet we just don't want to face an hour
demise or decrepitude or anything like
that by allowing extra damage so anyway
when one or the other of us has this and
you know we do this for other uh
ailments too we might not do it for a
cold
but for any significant uh disease we
tend to isolate and in this case
um we needed to do a live stream and as
there was I want people to think back to
early in our live streams we spent a lot
of time pointing out that the advice the
directives that we were being given the
policy changes that we were witnessing
made no sense the bulldozing of sand
into skate parks right these stopping
people from running on beaches and from
surfing the closing of parks this was
some of the earliest
most obviously completely wrong-headed
coveted policy that was frankly part of
what opened the door and opened many
people's eyes to
well if they're that wrong about those
things
what else are they wrong about yeah and
let's just put it to you this way wrong
isn't
pointlessly wrong
the fact is
to the extent that there was some
disease that we were trying to not catch
go outside was like healer advice go
outside right oh your life is being
disrupted you're facing psychological
torment go meet your friends outside too
cold and rainy figure out how to do it
right so
um in any case
we are outside today because although
you are you haven't had it very long we
treated too early of course I went on
prophylactic treatment now you and I
we're in close contact as you were
beginning to come down with it and so
it's possible that I got it and I will
uh manifest symptoms it's also possible
I got away with it or it's possible
because I went on what we think is
prophylactic treatment that my symptoms
will be so mild I won't even notice it
but in any case I thought it would be
interesting in light of the fact that we
are broadcasting from outside solving a
problem which is how do we do our job
while you may have a still active and
contagious infection well okay this
isn't perfect the lighting's not great
it's a little hot
um
there are airplane noises it's very nice
to see you it's great to sit next to the
last time we saw each other when we had
to curtail a short trip that you had
planned for us was on our 25th wedding
anniversary yep 25th wedding anniversary
and it was a delightful trip and I
really wish it hadn't been cut short
this you will all recognize is our book
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century and this book contains an
afterward which I am now going to read
Because it's what this is not how you
treat books
it's not how you treat books
okay well
um after the live stream we will have a
short tutorial on that no no we won't
okay all right
um so this is the afterward to
hunter-gatherers Guide to the 21st
century and I will do my attempt to read
it
in January of 2020 we went to the
tipatini biodiversity station in the
Ecuadorian Amazon to finish our first
draft of this book when we emerged from
our isolation as our phones came alive
for the first time in two weeks we were
confronted with a barrage of news mostly
trivial of which we had been blissfully
unaware but in that onslap Onslaught
there was one ominous report a case of a
novel coronavirus in Ecuador the
pathogen came from horseshoe bats had
jumped to people and then spread rapidly
first in Wuhan China and then beyond
as the two of us tried to make sense of
these first hints of a pandemic it
quickly became clear that there might be
more to the story Wuhan we soon learned
housed a bsl4 laboratory it was in fact
one of our planet's two main centers for
the research on bat-borne coronaviruses
these viruses were being studied in
Wuhan Wuhan and in North Carolina
because of fear among scientists that
such viruses could jump to people and
without very much evolutionary change
cause a dangerous pandemic if nothing
else the fact of the pandemic having
begun in one of two cities where these
viruses had been under intensive study
seemed a particular coincidence
as of the writing of this note in late
May 2021 the consensus in the scientific
establishment including National and
international regulators and the
mainstream press that follows them has
finally shifted to one of grudging
acceptance of the obvious that SARS kovi
2 May well have leaked from the Wuhan
Institute of virology
and the covid-19 pandemic might
therefore be for Humanity an entirely
self-inflicted wound
the strength of this hypothesis is
something we have been discussing on our
podcast Dark Horse since April of 2020.
those discussions caused a great deal of
derision and stigma to be directed at us
and it is bewildered it is a bewildering
relief to watch the world suddenly come
around to the plausibility of this
well-supported if unfortunate
explanation but no matter what Humanity
ultimately concludes about the
pandemic's origin there is a deeper
truth hovering just outside our
Collective awareness
covid-19 is a product of Technology no
matter what path it took to humans
consider this fact from the beginning of
the pandemic the virus showed
essentially zero capacity to transmit
outside put another way covid-19 is a
disease of buildings cars ships trains
and airplanes more than 99 percent of
the earth's surface is a coveted safe
Zone even in your own backyard the virus
will struggle mightily to infect anyone
it has no meaningful impact unless you
caught it before you walked out in the
park on the balcony at the beach we are
at least for now immune
the dependence of the virus on enclosed
spaces also means that had Humanity
agreed to avoid vectoring environments
for a few weeks the pandemic could have
been quickly brought to a halt but this
scenario in which we free ourselves and
lock down dangerous environments instead
is little more than an idle thought
experiment even though in evolutionary
terms these dangerous environments are
all brand new to humans the idea of
humanity staying outside them even for
just a few weeks is unthinkable
many individuals could do it but a
majority would be at a total loss even
though we evolved outside and despite
the fact that most of our ancestors
would have spent every hour of their
lives in what we now strangely call the
outdoors
we have forgotten the skills we once
knew so well
that knowledge of and comfort with our
natural environment has been replaced
with a different skill set one tuned to
pursuing value and avoiding harm in a
synthetic environment of our own device
our cognitive software has been
Rewritten and we have forgotten too much
to ever again be what we were the result
we are condemned to battle this pathogen
in bespoke environments in which we and
it have both grown to depend
that's the view from the ground but hum
but the human dimension of this pandemic
is even clearer from 30 000 feet or more
accurately at thirty thousand feet
for it is excuse me I have now now
reading in the shade
or it is the way we have begun to travel
that really sets us up for the pandemic
disaster SARS cov2 crossed oceans in
hours and it didn't Pioneer some
ingenious new mode where once an
epidemic might have been held back by
barriers that limit human travel humans
now regularly transmit communicable
diseases from their continents of origin
to every corner of the globe
much as people thought little about
washing their hands prior to the germ
theory of disease we give no thought to
the scale of misery caused by a given
person transporting a new and nameless
cold virus to some continent that was
free of it the day before
novel coronavirus took advantage of that
nonchalance before the pathogen even had
a proper name
the covid-19 pandemic is a self is it is
itself a symptom of another disease
entirely the pages of this book we call
that disease hyper novelty it is caused
by a rate of technological change so
rapid that transitions in our
environment outstrip our capacity to
adapt you will not find the covid-19
pandemic specifically dissected here but
you will find a full exploration of the
hyper-novelty crisis that left us
vulnerable to this virus a virus so weak
that it could have been cured with a bit
of well-coordinated fresh air
so I thought that revisit was worthwhile
in light of the fact that we are still
all dealing with the consequences of
this the people who have decided it's no
big deal the world is overcovered and
they're just not going to think about it
they're not going to do anything special
and the people who still treat it
seriously as you and I do and the people
who still panic over it and are wearing
their masks outside as they walk around
we still see these people occasionally
um the answer is there's actually a
loophole
with this disease the fact that it
doesn't transmit outside was a loophole
and a properly run Planet a planet in
which experts weren't
just simply idiots who held a high
position would have told us here is how
you go about not disrupting your life
try to figure out how to do as much as
possible outside and we can retain as
much normalcy as uh as we can arrange
but they didn't tell us that
no they told us exactly the opposite yes
they told us go inside go home
go go home get the people you love sick
if you're sick
uh and uh don't come back and see us
until it's uh close to too late at which
point we'll uh we'll inflict our worst
harms on you yeah we'll put you on a
ventilator and give you rem desevere uh
I don't know when that started that was
it was a little later but um you know
since replaced with um
next loaded but uh
um none of the solutions so-called uh
have been actually Solutions and that of
course as we have said over and over and
over again raises questions about uh
about why
so to what degree can we imagine they
were actually intended as Solutions in
the first place
um but here here we are in uh you know
in a summer where for a lot of people
it's been too hot it's been too smoky
it's been there have been too many fires
um to to go outside much and it that
being usually the season when people um
go out and uh re-up their vitamin D and
such
um still you should be trying and uh you
know everyone's in a in a different
different Locale but your particular
situation uh personal social emotional
uh should not be the one driving whether
or not you should be going outside if
there if there are reasons that you that
you can't be outside because because of
fires because of storms whatever that's
something different but
um really the um
the more time you spend outside the more
time you spend moving your body being
active getting every part of you moving
uh the healthier you're going to be
[Music]